what are the most common problems that
you see let's just stick with couples I
mean what's the most common
common problems not meeting each other's
needs because they don't know what each
other's needs are loving someone the way
that they feel comfortable loving versus
loving the way that the other person
needs to be loved lack of communication
is really I mean all relationship
problems could basically boil down to a
communication problem
I mean if you peel away the onion far
enough at the core what you get is a
communication breakdown because people
get in their heads they start creating
stories they start creating meanings
and they they're we're constantly
projecting and communication is
something that we were not taught in
school and it requires it does not
require Perfection it just requires
courage
it requires vulnerability
and you know kindness like if you love
someone and all you do is criticize them
or blame them is that loving it's not
so but you could say I really love this
person but your behavior is not loving
so it's it's really teaching people how
to communicate and actually love each
other is it a matter of the finding the
right person or becoming the right
person it's both
it's both
um I I think that who you choose matters
but a lot of people will choose based on
like a checklist instead of choosing
based on what is actually essential own
well-being and psychology seems like
there's even there's more opportunity
than ever to be hurt in relationships
because it seems like they we don't it's
not like the 50s where you just stick it
out and yeah I mean they were hurting
too I think in just a different way
right there I think they were definitely
hurting but I think that you know with
social media and a million dating apps
and like the threats are everywhere yeah
I think that you know in the 50s there
was just a lot more certainty it's like
we got married we stay married you know
and now it's like well I can have this
option over here and the grass is
greener over there
then maybe I can do that over there and
so
that does make people feel incredibly
uncertain and much more vulnerable to
rejection for sure
well within that realm of social media
and dating apps and things like that
what's the line there like meaning
should you be able to see each other's
information should you like there's
always that there's always that sort of
um issue in relationships where you like
you want to look at their phone or if
you but you you think if I do I
shouldn't be here anyway or if I feel
like I need to I think that if you feel
like you need to look at your partner's
phone there's two things that could be
going on number one you're bringing your
old baggage from an old relationship
into your current relationship or
something is not going well in the in
your current relationship you don't feel
connected you're suspicious of something
trust is the most important thing in a
relationship so you should um not feel
like you have to check your partner's
phone and if you do it's definitely an
alert and and some people I've worked
with they have felt that impulse just
because they've been cheated on in the
past but it's not it really has nothing
to do with their current relationship
it's really about them being able to
build that trust muscle within
themselves
and for others it's because they felt
they felt disconnected they suspect
something is going on but it's not a
good sign good relationships it's like
if you're in a relationship and let's
just say you know it's not an early
relationship like you're in it you've
been together maybe you're married
you're partnered and then you go out for
dinner and let's just say you forgot
your phone but you really have to check
something like important it's like a
work thing if you and then you you
should be able to say to your partner
can I have your phone I have to check
something and they should be like yeah
of course if there is like I think it's
you should you should have each other's
codes only for that there should be so
much trust
so much trust that No One's Gonna Snoop
so much trust that like there's nothing
that you're hiding that's the level of
trust that is really necessary in a
relationship right because that's
actually the same but different right
there should be so much trust that like
the trust is I'm not gonna look at it
but the trust is here's my code yeah
exactly right
opposite sides of the coin exactly what
happens when trust has been broken
depends how it's been broken was it
broken because an affair was it broken
because your partner said that they
wanted to do this for a living and they
decided to Pivot and do something else
for a living you know they changed in
some way was trust broken because I
don't know they didn't keep a secret
what is the pathway back to trusting
especially for both sides for the person
that's learning how to trust again and
for the person that is trying to earn
the trust again
apology and accountability
so if someone has betrayed
a loved one's Trust
they have to be extremely remorseful
and they have to be very apologetic
and very accountable if it's an affair
Affairs can be extremely complicated and
oftentimes what you'll find is that it's
not a 50 50 split of who's responsible
but even the person who was cheated on
if they want to work on the relationship
they will see that they played a role in
whatever was not working in the
relationship it does not condone the
behavior right right it doesn't make
them doesn't mean they're not wrong but
it's just that you can see the full
picture you can see the full picture if
you want to repair right if you want to
repair you have to repair what was
damaged in the relationship that kind of
led to that if if it's a big betrayal
like an infidelity they cannot do it
alone you need a third party how early
should that be something that comes into
the relationship
that there's a lot of value in doing it
really early on
to learn how to communicate best for a
problem before the problem
absolutely because a lot of people go
into couples therapy when it's become
too late right and it's not even like
when the problem starts it's like this
is like our last ditch effort yeah this
is our we feel desperate what is it that
a man looks for in a relationship and
what does a whim a woman generally look
for in a relationship well I think that
similar than they are different
which is love and companionship I think
women value connection at a really high
level
and I think that typically what you have
found is that men will value sort of
like their purpose maybe at a higher
level but things are changing and I
think that uh both women and men need to
find some sort of purpose I think for
women it doesn't necessarily have to be
through work for every woman but I think
everyone needs purpose but I think both
men and women are in it for the same
thing but where
for attraction to happen inside of a
relationship
there has to be polarity there has to be
a duality and so women typically who are
attracted to men and even some women who
are attracted to women
typically are attracted to strength and
what they will do is unconsciously test
every partner
poke poke at them push their buttons
because what they're doing on an
unconscious level is figuring out like
are you gonna protect me in a foxhole
typically that's not what men are
looking for maybe there's some gay men
who who are looking for that who are
looking for that strength and protection
but typically what men are looking for
is that they want to be they want to
really be appreciated and they want to
actually be the hero
and they really want to be respected in
that way and seen as strong
and they want to like the most
attractive thing for a man who dates a
woman in particular is
is she gonna let me in
am I going to be let into her heart
yeah
or because it's because if it's if it's
constant I don't need you
it's very rejecting
neediness doesn't work either right
right neither this doesn't work either
but I think that women typically will
get into a relationship to feel a sense
of safety and protection and I don't
think that men value that but they don't
value that as much as women do do you
mean physical safety and protection
emotional physical all of the all of the
above like what does it look to be
emotionally available so I've worked
with many men I've worked with more
women than men but I've worked with a
lot of men and
um their Chief complaint in
relationships is
I'm not appreciated
nothing I ever do is good enough for her
or for him she's stressed out so much
that I can't I feel like I can't connect
to her heart is closed you know I don't
feel like I'm
this is not what they're saying but this
is the meaning behind it I don't feel
like I could be the one who can just
like make her life better she's not
letting me do that this side this like
idea or experience of containment
feels really powerful can you explain
what that is
you mean the the masculine containment
yeah from for a man to be able to
provide containment
yeah so I think that one of the hardest
things for women
and I've worked with plenty of gay women
who have who struggled this with other
women but in general like women with men
is
he can't
it's like his threshold to be able to
handle
difficult emotion is very low
um
and when I'm upset
he wants to fix it and what I need is
for him to be so with me and so present
and that's actually what heals me in the
moment if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen